[Music]
seventh lecture in the fall series God
and computers mines machines and
metaphysics we are right now in the
second part of the series the first part
dealt with what was called the human
factor what what is intelligence what is
cognition and stuff like that in the
second part now we have a kind we have
several case studies where people
present their own point of view how they
as scientists deal with existential
issues within and outside of their
research we had first Frederico Jiro see
from a Christian perspective last week
there was Francisco Varela from a
Buddhist perspective today we have Lin
from a Jewish perspective and next week
we hear me joy misra from a Hindu
perspective and then the last two
sections deal with can be rebuilt it and
that we will have records while on
spiritual machines and rusty car on
building machines which can deny their
maker so in that sense we are right in
the middle of today and just just an
announcement like Thanksgiving we don't
have a lecture of course one day before
Thanksgiving because I don't expect
anyone would come but if you still want
to do something with God in computers
this week we have on Monday our
discussion group at Harvard Divinity
School run by Harvey Cox and me so if
you're interested either write me email
my email address is a and an EF at AI
dot mit.edu or just come to the Harvard
Divinity School 45 Francis Avenue in the
refectory which is the dining hall sort
of stuff we meet at 12 o'clock it's in
this brochure unfortunately at one
o'clock but it's at 12 o'clock if you're
interested in the whole project
I have brochures again last week I
didn't have them so pick up a brochure
if you're interested in what we are
doing and now I would very much like to
welcome Lyn Lyn Andrea Stein who is
right now associate professor of
electrical engineering and computer
science and member of the AI lab and the
laboratory of computer science
here at MIT Lynne has received her PhD
from Brown in 1990 and has since then
been at MIT and she worked on a variety
of topics beside other projects she
worked on questions of cognitive science
and robotics common sense reasoning
software agents and human-computer
interactions
she has also spoken several times on
questions on gender issues for how is it
to be a women woman in computer science
and especially at MIT and her specific
interest is in question on pedagogy she
received besides other awards like for
instance the National Science Foundation
Young Investigator award the Ruth and
Joel Spira Teaching Award in 1995 and
right now just won a fellowship of the
bunting Institute at Harvard where she
will continue this mm-hmm
Radcliffe oh sorry isn't that the same
all right where she will continue this
this research in summer I met Lynne in
nineteen eight nineteen ninety three
when she was co-teaching of course
called embodiment and cognition together
with Rodney Brooks and despite our
different backgrounds and different
opinions and a lot of things we have
been since then friends and often have
been involved in very lively debates
about the nature of human cognition the
relationship of science and religion and
many more topics and in the center of
all these discussions stood for her not
necessarily a search for truth but the
attempt to reconcile different
approaches to life and these discussions
were also based on the willingness to
engage in an open-ended and not
judgmental dialogue and Lena's in my
experience one of the very few people in
the lab who makes time to engage a lot
in those issues and I'm very happy that
you're here today to share your thoughts
with us welcome
[Applause]
hi I have just a few overheads and so
I'd like it if most of the time we could
have the lights beyond that way I could
actually see you as well as having you
see me but for those of you who didn't
receive the tremendous publicity that
there's been the title of my talk is all
is for known but free will is given as
Anna mentioned this talk is very much a
case study that is I want to tell you
about myself and what my perspectives on
religion and science are sorry if they
warned me to stand on this side of the
projector and I will not for the most
part be telling you about my work one
thing that is true both of my work on
the whole and my approach to religion is
that I believe that stories are really
at the center of everything and so for
today I'd like to tell you the story of
my religious perspective and the story
to some extent of how I'm affected by
that as a scientist and how I reconcile
being a religious person and being a
scientist well let me start with the
title of the talk because I wrote it
thinking one thing and many read it
thinking another and I found it
interesting and and both I hope to do
justice to in my talk when I wrote the
title of the talk or rather when I chose
the tale because it is after all a very
old quotation I chose it because of its
apparently paradoxical nature and I find
myself as a religious person and a
scientist it enmeshed in such a paradox
and I want to talk to you about my view
of paradox because it affects both my
view of religion and my view of
reconciling that with my professional
life but many people told me that they
were coming to hear me speak on a free
will and so let me tell you that I will
touch briefly on the idea of free will
and in fact I'd like to both begin and
end with
paradox but for the most part the talk
will not be about free will those of you
who really want to know the details of
my belief on free will can corner me
after the talk so let me begin with free
will because it is the paradox in the
title and point out things both that I
knew before and that arose after I chose
this as a title to me
the title is inherently paradoxical in
the sense that if all is indeed
foreknown how can it be possible that we
have free will that is if all is
determined how can we be choosing what
we do but Amma pointed out to me that
this was not originally seen as a
paradox and in fact if you look at it
from a purely religious perspective it's
not clear that there's a paradox here so
if you take for knowledge to be
independent of how we choose what we do
then there isn't necessarily a paradox
at the heart of this statement it's only
when you add in the idea of determinism
which draws largely from the Scientific
Revolution the idea that if everything
is determined then there can be no
choice that this statement becomes a
paradox and so this statement is
paradoxical precisely because we choose
to apply something of the scientific
worldview and my interpretation my
reconciliation of this statement is in
part to accept the scientific
perspective and in part to live outside
the scientific perspective so those are
the themes that will run through my talk
the idea of being within the scientific
perspective but at the same time being
outside the scientific perspective and
the theme of the talk is paradox and
science here is a search for truth and I
want to discuss to what extent that
search for truth is a sensible or
desirable enterprise okay so let me tell
you now about the very first paradox I
ever can
so the talk is divided into three
portions the first deals with liar
paradox is a phrase I'll explain to
those of you who are not familiar to it
we'll deal essentially with three
different phases of paradox so the very
first paradox that I ever encountered at
least that I never remembered
encountering something I learned when I
must have been about six or eight some
perverse relative told me that every
rule has an exception this seemed okay
for a little while and then I realized
that most of the rules I knew had
exceptions so it seemed like a true
statement now I realize that so many of
the rules I knew had exceptions that it
might be that this rule was in fact it's
own exception and then problem struck
because after all if this statement is
the sole exception to the rule every
rule has an exception then it cannot be
that it's true nor can it be that it's
false so if we assume that every rule
has an exception then there must be an
exception to this rule but if this rule
is the exception to the statement every
rule has an exception then every rule
has an exception and this rule has no
exception this was my first experience
with statements that could not be either
true or false and as you stare at it the
statement flickers back and forth and
you can look at it from either side but
you can't really reconcile the two
perspectives so here's a visual analogue
just for fun this is a famous figure
which if you look at the black is a
picture of a Vaz or a cup but if you
look at the white is a picture of two
faces and you can see either picture but
you really can't see both at once
and neither account fully describes this
picture so there's something there the
not true and it's not false that's not
lack and that's not white and that is in
fact the nature of paradox and it's not
our inability to see beyond it that
makes it so it is true of these
statements in these pictures there's a
name for this particular form of paradox
the every rule has an exception it's
called the it's called a liar paradox
and the classical liar paradox is a
minor variant on this this is actually a
little closer to a girdle sentence but
there are in part of my career I
actually studied some of the formal
aspects of paradox and the statement
this sentence is false is as close as I
can come in English to the formal
logical paradoxes but I looked at this
statement cannot be true nor can it be
false if it were true then it would be
false and if it were false then it would
be true and this statement or one very
much like it is at the heart of the
incompleteness proof for first-order
logic that proof says that no logic can
prove no logical theory can prove
everything which is true in it that is
there are things which can be true that
cannot be proved in logics of a certain
power and some people have taken that to
mean the computers can never be
intelligent because there are things
that logics and computers are
essentially logical machines cannot do
others have taken that as a statement
about language there's something wrong
with a logical form of language such
that it can't capture what this sentence
is about let me tell you about two
logical attempts to grapple with this
problem which I learned about from a
technical perspective
and which I think are unsatisfying from
what one might call theological or
religious perspective the first is a
statement or an argument that this
particular sentence is operating at
multiple levels and the reason that this
sentence is paradoxical has to do with
the levels at which the sentence is
operating so by saying this sentence is
false that's referring to sort of ground
truth false might call it false sub zero
and that statement because it's a
statement at level zero
he's judge true or false at level one so
this statement might be true at level
one but false at level zero the problem
is that if you say that then you can
construct a statement about level one
and only judge that at level two and so
on and so on until you get into infinite
regress and although I believe that
there's something infinite about the
world I also believe that's not a
satisfying resolution to say the problem
is true or false just exists at so many
levels they do fine but ultimately for
any level I can tell you a statement
that won't be true or false at that
level so there must be something more
and a third alternative another
alternative is to say this statement
isn't true and it isn't false it is in
fact something other and there are
multiple multivalued logics which allow
for truth values which are neither true
nor false and then this statement is a
sign that other value and that gets a
little closer to me that is I think
there's something more than true or
false but in three-valued logic so you
can also construct paradoxes and again
escaping by saying there's something
else but it is qualitatively the same as
these statements that are problematic
it's simply a little different will add
us
script or will add an extra truth value
that seems to me not to get at the heart
of what the paradox is about instead I
think the reason paradox exists is that
truth and falsity are an inadequate
dimension against which to judge certain
things and paradoxes are statements that
bring home that idea certainly there are
a lot of things in our lives that are
neither true nor false there are things
which are true in degrees there are
things which are true in type or in
qualitatively so there are things which
are true approximately my height is five
six or five seven or those are maybe
sort of true I love my husband well
that's true but truth somehow is
inadequate to express the particular way
I feel about him and so in some ways
like the all is for known and free will
is determined we're led to paradox in
these statements because we look at
things through the scientists eyes
because we say true or false ought to be
adequate measure for this statement but
instead I think and I think both as a
scientist and as a religious person that
there is more than truth and falsity and
truth and falsity are notions that we as
scientists use to approximate some of
those other things and sometimes they're
very powerful notions but at other times
they fall short and we need to recognize
when they fall short this idea also
implies that there are questions that
science can't answer so I'd like to turn
now to paradox is a finite approximation
and some of why science may not be able
to answer
a paradox I learned a little later in my
life I think I was in high school at the
time
what is the paradox that if you take
nine tenths and nine hundredths in 99 90
hundreds if you take point 9 and you
repeat it an infinite number of times
that is the same as 1 this was a very
disturbing paradox for me every
exception has a rule every rule has an
exception was not nearly so disturbing
to me
this one really really upset me I
remember being at summer camp and lying
on a star on a hill staring up at a
starry sky and this is such a trite
image I hate to tell you but lying there
staring up at the stars and thinking how
can this be true and I guess this shows
that I'm an ultimate MIT nerd because
for me this was a major existential
crisis
but it really really disturbed me and uh
let me put up another version of the
paradox that that I don't like quite as
much but let me tell you that Zeno's
paradox which is a variant on this and
then I'll come back to this one okay
Gerry Sussman uh yells at me all the
time that that was not a paradox but to
me it is it's as disturbing as any
paradox I know so this is the
mathematical statement of Zeno's paradox
Zeno's paradox is if I want to get from
here to there and I in the first instant
I go half way and in the next instant I
go half of the remaining distance and in
the next instant I go half of that the
distance left and so on
I will never reach my goal and
mathematically that's like the infinite
sum of 1 over 2 to the N which you'll
also tell me is not a paradox that this
infinite sum should be 1 but when you
say it in lay language it sure sounds
like it's going to take an infinite
amount of time to cross a finite
distance and that's disturbing I know
it's because we're mathematically naive
and unsophisticated but I think that the
heart of both of these paradoxes is the
idea I'm gonna put this one out because
I like it better is the paradox of
finite approximation so if indeed I
could somehow encompass the infinity of
this number then I would indeed have
reached 1 if I could encompass the
infinity of time it would take me to
cross halfway from here to there and so
on and so on I would have reached my
goal but I am a finite being and I
cannot encompass that infinity now I
know a mathematical trick to let me
pretend that I am but when I sit down to
think about it I can think of 0.9 or
0.99 0.999
but at anytime I can only understand a
finite number of those knives I can only
imagine a finite number of steps to
reach my goal and so there is in me a
limit to how far I can go in spite of
the fact that I can't think in an
objective but non intuitive way about
the infinity of things required to get
to someplace and what I came up with
lying on the hillside staring up at the
stars was a realization that what is in
here is an attempt to capture that
infinity in a way that was very
reminiscent to me of a theological
difficulty in Judaism we believe that
the Messiah has not yet come and in
essentially all movements of Judaism
there's a strong belief which desire
that someday the Messiah and the Messiah
should come different versions different
movements within Judaism have different
versions of this goal this ideal and
different imaginings of what it would be
like but in all there is this yearning
for the day that the Messiah comes and
on certain holidays we talk about the
coming of the Messiah and this is
something that from my youngest days was
held up to me has a thing towards which
one should aspire now it's also
problematic because if the Messiah comes
the world ain't gonna be like it is and
although there are some things about the
world I'm not very comfortable with
there are some other things that I like
so
even when I was young I saw this as a
problematic notion and yet my religion
teaches me this is what I should wish
for what I should aspire to and yet
again there's a story a Midrash we have
in Judaism there are a lot of stories
there's a story
the messiah will come if every Jew
observed Shabbat one Sabbath every Jew
observes then the Messiah will come and
yet get to Jews in a true view of three
opinions this is not about to happen
when will the Messiah come will the
Messiah to me okay it's a naive nerd
like notion the Messiah to me is like
point-9 repeating at any time we can't
be there we're finite our view of the
world is finite
I think scientifically that the world is
finite so I will never see the coming of
the Messiah I'm a dream for it wish for
it but it can't be accessible to me nor
will my children see it nor their
children nor any finite number of
generations and yet somehow in the
infinite potential infinity of
tomorrow's is the coming of the Messiah
so very nerd like I told you but this is
this is me as case study
you're like a under lab glass um
this to me is paradoxical because I
can't encompass this infinity and yet I
know that this is true
so so if this is true if I'm finite but
I live in an infinite world how do i
reconcile being a scientist and being a
religious person and how is it that I
put together the fact that the idea that
to me there is something that is more
than true and false and yet as a
scientist I speak in the language of
truth and falsity well there are a lot
of things in the world and some of them
are very mysterious
I guess the place to start is to
recognize that there are things not only
that I don't know but that I will never
know that I can't know and yet
that must be sought for and science is
in many ways like adding digits
two-point-nine repeating science is
trying to get a better approximation on
the world we know with the understanding
that I won't see one and my students
won't see one and their students won't
see one and in fact surprisingly enough
the more you know the more you know
there is to know and you don't know um
and I don't think that's coincidence at
all I think that is in fact the nature
of the world there's always further to
go there's always more to do and that's
true from a religious perspective and
that's also true from a scientific
perspective and accepting that both
inspires me because there's always
someplace else to go and intimidates me
gives me all in the original sense of
the word I am struck with awe at the
magnitude of the task before us
there's a saying which I learned first
as a song and if I sang any better than
Paul I would I would sing it for you
Lola ha ha ha look more the lot have
been harina liebe tell me Mina it's not
a it's not incumbent upon you to finish
the work but neither are you free from
attempting it from from trying and
that's a fundamental message of this
idea of truth as being the inaccessible
infinite or maybe truth is the wrong
word but I think that scientific truth
is like that as well I think that when
we build our Tower of levels of truth
values we can continue to approximate
the truth and falsity of any finite liar
paradox but there will always be a
paradox yet remaining there's always a
higher level of the paradox and the goal
of complete understanding is always just
outside our grasp so to return to the
paradox at the beginning of my talk how
is it that i reconcile determinism and
freewill
well for me as a scientist and in
particular in the field of artificial
intelligence in order to engage in an
attempt to create an intelligent
artifact I must be an indeed and as a
professional deeply committed to the
idea that there is nothing in me that
cannot be understood but I'm deeply
committed to that in the sense that I'm
deeply committed to 0.9 repeating being
one if I had infinite time if I had
infinite resources I must accept that
everything in me is physical has an ant
has an answer there are questions of
measurement there are questions of
certain kinds of combinations that can't
be known paradox I chose not to talk
about is Heisenberg's but the idea is
all there is to me could in principle be
known and as a scientist I am committed
to that as a religious person I am
deeply agnostic about a question of
determinism and in fact I hope it's not
true
but as a scientist I accept that perhaps
it is knowable I assume that enough of
it is knowable to make my work in
attempting to build intelligent
creatures agents artifacts useful
worthwhile and I hope that by adding
digits to the infinitely repeating
number I'm assisting in the
approximation of the truth that may or
may not be reachable just as the Messiah
may never come in any finite
approximation so determinism for me is a
working hypothesis in spite of the fact
that it doesn't make my everyday life
very comfortable and I reconcile myself
with that in part I don't know if this
one copied well enough I reconciled that
in part by only looking at part of the
picture and I'm all too aware that I do
this I mean after all if you if you look
at the man on the ladder he's doing just
fine he's gonna climb up onto that
balcony or if you look at these steps
they lead up to this other balcony and
it's only when you step back far enough
to see the hole that you realize that
there may be some disturbing
inconsistencies here have you seen it it
is in fact physically impossible for the
building to be so constructed there's a
perspective shift when you go between
the first and second levels but those
are perspective shifts that we all make
all the time and sometimes when we're
pushed we even know we make them maybe
free will is a post hoc rationalization
of the choices we already made I
actually happen to think that that
applies to consciousness our conscious
thought is a post hoc rationalization of
the things our brain and body
did for us and that particular insight
involves some of my work with robots if
if that's the way the world is it's it's
got these weird inconsistencies in it
it's got these unknowable things these
things we can't ever quite reach the
things that fall between true and false
and we can retain our bearings just by
looking at a part of the picture at once
there's something a bit disconcerting
about that and it would be nice
sometimes to step back and see the whole
thing and be able to accept the whole
picture without having this uneasy
flitting back and forth changing of
perspectives to me this comes to the
question of what is God what is that
which is not human bound by the world
physical and as I said I am not merely
as a scientist a determinist but a
strong materialist even in my
non-scientific views I believe that I am
built out of atoms and not eternal
immortal soul
I don't accept that there is something
inside my body or supervenient on it
that is divine and yet I believe that
there is a God I I'd like to try to
explain to you what I believe God is and
I have to tell you this is a deeply
embarrassing thing for a practicing
scientist to get up and do particularly
in front of one's colleagues there are
certain experiences that are so profound
so deep so moving so all-encompassing
that I cannot say I had those
experiences
I simply was those experiences looking
back I can reflect on them I I know I
was a part and not the whole of the
experience and yet during those instants
I was the experience that night on the
starry hill as a teenager was one of
them
childbirth was three of them there was a
moment in the middle of my wedding
ceremony that was one of them I have
very few memories of the actual wedding
ceremony because it was an experience I
was so deeply inside that I was the
experience I'm not going to tell you
about some of the other experiences that
have been like that I've been privileged
to have had many experiences like that
though they are instance points in a
huge space of my life but in those
experiences I came as close as I think
it is possible to come to that which is
divine true and false were immaterial
notions in those instance there was no
finite approximation to the experience I
was the experience there was no me
separate from the world it was simply a
state of being perhaps the best
description I've heard of this by a
theologian is boobers thou though I hate
that way of phrasing it but there is a
thing which is so intense that it is
overwhelming and it is not something
beyond the physical
if anything it is more deeply physical
in childbirth it was so because the pain
was so intense and overwhelming that
there was no conscious nee I simply was
the experience I think that is very
close to what God is God is the infinite
that makes the finite approximations
possible it is that towards which we
drive it is the coming of the Messiah it
is some of what exists between true and
false or outside of them and that notion
of God a naive scientists notion of God
for the theologians in the audience is
to me the thing that is divinity someone
asked me in a part of a group of
religious people um how do you deal with
the question of how could God allowed
the Shoah the Holocaust and it was
interesting to go around the room and
hear different people's answers but I
have to tell you that for me frankly
that question is a type mismatch it's
one of the few things I can say to saw
interests in the audience that the
theologians hopefully will have to
struggle with a little and can't quite
look down on me for okay so what is a
type mismatch there are things that you
can do with certain kinds of things and
not with others right well it makes
sense to talk about whether it's a nice
car a big car a red car right it doesn't
really make sense to talk about whether
it's a thoughtful car a moral car a
valiant car those are tight mismatches
they are questions that are nonsensical
to ask about the artifact to me to ask
how God could have allowed the show of
how God could have allowed the Holocaust
is a nonsensical question given the
notion of God I have just described to
you
God is not a thing period full stop but
God is not anything such that it makes
sense for God to have intervened or not
intervened to have
knitted or not permitted that isn't what
religion religiosity the divine is to me
so to me God is that towards which we
strive it is the infinite towards which
we are making finite approximations
it is that which lies between and
outside true and false and there is an
again a Jewish notion whether these
religious beliefs can be attributed to
my Jewish upbringing I can't say but
certainly culturally I am a very Jewish
person and there is a notion in Judaism
of tikkun olam completing the world that
is what that is the labor it is
incumbent upon us to try
why am ia scientist in the hope in the
aspiration that I can help rebuild the
world help to make it complete but in
the full knowledge and understanding
that for the world to be complete is
beyond any finite approximation is
outside true and false requires
something that science alone does not
empower me to achieve and that no
property of my finite mortality can ever
get me to I just wanted to close with
some very very very feeble attempts at
scientific mysticism there are some
things that look perfectly plausible and
when you look deeper turn out to be
pretty deeply implausible and this is
one of them and there are other things
that just seem like they ought to be
impossible but our common parts of our
everyday world thank you
[Applause]
do you want to answer them or do you
wanna do you want to oh yeah that's okay
I think that's another example of the
impossibility of ever arriving the
question was a pointer to pickles notion
of thesis antithesis and then synthesis
but synthesis becoming the new thesis I
don't know if people in the back can
hear but I think that that's another
wonderful example and there are many of
approximating and then moving on and
maybe even completing and yet somehow
not completing always leaving a next
step and I know of very few things that
can ever truly be called complete so
then I think you pull the possible and
here's why
use a computing analogy I put a lot of
faith in something rather tragic I have
years worth of documents and email but
I'm consigned to Windows NT and you are
the tonight theorist you comes along
when I ask you the big question in my
life when will it crash how did it crash
you Tommy it's tightly consistent I
can't ask that question it doesn't exist
and what tells me is that you've taken
what I think of very real dilemmas why
should it turn isn't about which is not
only whiskey forever it's a rain one day
an intractable one it's basically if I
have a clock how can I be blamed for
failing a class or not
right my just ticked away in the
basement instructions and when we seem
to have done it conversion is very build
our members into linguistic ones and
it's my impression that the paradox as
you showed the reason why comfortable
with them is because we somehow
determine is not being real they're just
it constructs right the notion of
abstraction mathematically isn't
infinite abstraction I say exactly the
opposite I believe very passionately in
the reality of infinity and and it was
there was an example just before the
infinite that you used other than after
Microsoft at grantee but no after that
after that Oh Oh the the importance of
these questions I think that these
questions are tremendously significant
they are tremendously important and it's
not that because their language they
don't bother me I believe the
fundamental truth reality of paradox and
it really it's not that I can brush
aside the the liar sentence by saying
well it's just a construct of language
the language gives us the ability to see
something that is real that is almost
physical that is visceral and to me it's
not that these things are simply our
linguistic misunderstanding it's that
language is giving us insight into the
fact that the world is deeply
paradoxical it's deeply deeply
inconsistent that's so and physics gives
us the illusion that it's consistent so
I I guess I don't want to brush aside
the question of determinism simply
because I'm a clock I mean maybe a cloth
can be held responsible maybe by
reducing things to logical terms
we're claiming distinctions that don't
really exist because these things are
true they are real they are physical but
I also should say that I'm not trying to
proselytize I have a very bizarre
theology and I don't think you should
adopt it if it doesn't work for you I'm
just putting myself forth under the
microscope for you to examine it and and
Wow though I'm deeply serious
yeah I know which slit the photon went
through if I know whether Heisenberg's
cat is dead or alive
then if I know and I am right in that
knowing then it's more than just
knowledge it's a fact about the world
and I guess you could still argue and I
guess I may be arguing that there is
more than fact about the world but to
know is not to act
what to know and know rightly is to
constrain possibility and to act is
either to open possibility or to
foreclose it
[Music]
and the dichotomies no result it depends
whether I know what is or also how I
will change how it will change and in
all is foreknown I take it to be not
just a knowledge of what is at any
instant but that infinite knowing of now
and future evolution what are the rules
that govern the system to use a very
mechanistic term but I I agreed that the
paradox comes about in part because of
this reduction to the material not
because I believe there is a realm other
than the material but because we are
used to thinking in terms of the
material as constraining there's a body
of mysticism which is coming in too much
vogue now called Kabbalah it's Jewish
mysticism and I aspire someday to study
it but it is forbidden to study the
Kabbalah before you're 40
but then would you describe God your
experience of God I would my technical
way of stating that I would say that you
weren't aware of the men of the meta
makes you aware of unconsciousness but
you were you were expressing experiences
of which the meta went away he would
just strictly that's the way if that's
the case then I don't understand how
that could be the definition of God
given that you were building up to an
essence this extra action well first of
all I I hope I didn't say I was defining
God because I don't know that I can I
was attempting to describe but second I
think that your idea of the meta is is a
very evocative one for most of my life
not only am I having experiences but I'm
watching myself have these experiences
and I'm watching myself watching myself
have these experiences and I don't
usually operate on all of those
different levels and yet anytime I want
to have access to all of those levels
and what happens in those moments where
I am the experience isn't exactly a
collapse of that infinite regression or
a potentially infinite regression there
is only the experience there is no me
outside the experience to be watching
and so that if me outside the experience
watching is the incomplete fraction in
some ways then the being the experience
is exactly that kind of collapse into
the infinite but I also think I said
that that was as close to experiencing
the divine as I could come and I don't
know if it is possible to experience the
divine I only know that for me those
moments have been transcendent know
enough about laser coherence to answer
that question
perhaps I I just don't know enough about
the technical under this subject to know
whether I feel like those justice to the
metaphor and these are after all only
metaphors as a scientist I should think
you will probably not want to make
statements about things that are not
observable and what you're talking about
when you take the point nine nine nine
nine nine
pretty soon as I head to a point where
there is no conceivable way that you
will ever observe the difference between
that there's a continuity involved in
mathematics between the point nine nine
nine and one and the error is actually
measurable and very small you are trying
and and at some point your measurement
is impossible to distinguish those two
and therefore they become from a
scientific point of view of the same
concept the same construct and you
should not worry about whether one's
infinitely different than the other it
seems to me but your other examples also
fail them too you're attempting to get a
discrete interpretation of what is
basically a continuous situation the
liars paradox the simplest form of which
is I lie that's the simplest form of a
paragraph has an exact analogy in logic
where you've taken inverter and connect
the output to the input and that's the
question
equals waters one equals zero and we all
know as engineers that that's a type
error in the sense that you've taken the
digital abstraction and and you have
violated it and naturally something
outside of the digital abstraction is
going to happen so the things that are
possibly or does some other thing I
don't know why these paradoxes yeah
can't have similar interpretation you
just didn't it that that the statement
this sentence is false is an
approximation to something vastly more
complex and depending on what you think
of this is an approximation to
resolution of the paradox what different
those in those ways and so it seems to
me that by choosing a paradox asked your
mechanism for getting at God you are
violating your own rule as a scientist
to avoid things which are unmeasurable
what there's so many things I want to
say that to begin with while I'm baring
my soul scientist really isn't the
phrase I'd like I have aspirations to be
an applied philosopher although I hear
that term has been co-opted by the
medical ethicists but but I I in fact
I'm deeply concerned not just with a
physical but with a metaphysical and I
think that given that it's easier to
understand why your measurement error
isn't for me a satisfactory resolution I
could always build a better measuring
device I might never for any measuring
device there would be an unmeasurable
small error but there would always be a
better measuring device not yet when
we've used all the atoms in the universe
maybe we can I mean maybe we can use
them more efficiently maybe we can
mention your smaller devices maybe a
sign
science is in part about what isn't yet
possible but will be someday
and so maybe not maybe maybe there will
be something that is so small as to be
immaterial and yet as a philosopher I'll
know it's there and and the Sun will
probably explode first and said this
whole conversation in this whole line of
argument is moot but still I'm concerned
with what is so as much as with what is
measurable as to the logical paradoxes
like the liar sentence in English we can
talk about it's being a finite
approximation to something much more
complex but I can state the girdle
sentence and I can't look at that as a
finite approximation to something more
complex it is outside the notion of
provable in the case of the girdle
sentence I can state things and I in a
former life I lived in a world of logic
and I I do see that the logical analogs
of these paradoxes as deeply problematic
in what they say about truth and falsity
and if you believe logic to be
attempting to approximate those notions
we're really attempting to get a handle
on those notions there is something
beyond and that seems to me to be true
of the world but that's something I say
on faith and I can't prove to you
scientifically there are a lot of other
things but let me give some other people
chances to ask questions
however might be at that point becomes
this question of anatomy and creation
sense but in the infinite sense you know
well did we just become God in the sense
that we have infinite knowledge with
respect to the system or since this
system doesn't have this infinite
expanse is it really alive or
intelligence BCR trouble getting my
audio-visual equipment to work only to
discover that it's not plugged in I
don't assume that I have complete
knowledge of the system whether or not
it's infinite knowledge depends on what
you wanted to define this finite and
infinite and what dimensions you want to
take I I question your premise to begin
with that having built the system we
therefore have complete knowledge of it
but even should I accept that question I
think that there is more that is needed
in order to address the questions of
whether it could be alive whether it
could be conscious etc so simply the
fact that I've created something
certainly doesn't bear on whether it
could be alive or not alive
there's very little that went on in the
creation of my children that didn't
directly and viscerally involve me and
yet they are certainly alive and there
are other things I create in quite
different fashion that are certainly not
alive big question outside the scope of
this talk
they create a three-dimensional
sculpture say it had those same
properties that the picture seems to
have so yeah the two-dimensional
representation it comes up with these
quirks but that doesn't mean that
they're three dimensionality asswad
because we can draw this picture that
means that two dimensionality is not you
know the end-all as far as capturing
that and I guess I would make kind of a
really large you know leap by analogy
and say that human-like language or
human understanding as a whole is only
to be approximation to the nature of the
world the idea that you know all the
computing power we have available can't
predict what's gonna happen in a cubic
into water or something and it's you
know it's just a mathematical or the
kind of a logical fact that you know you
can't know everything about every atom
or every particle in the universe
because you need a whole like shadow
thing to hold all that information and
so you know it's a different kind of
like dimensionality collapse are like
understanding of things it's gonna
naturally has to be you know an
approximation or we can't be those
particles we can't be the astroturf or a
planet or something approximations of
the entirety of that which they attempt
to represent absolutely always gonna
happen but then to turn on say oh hey
there's always gonna be this gap but I
choose at this very high level like the
difference is the slip between two
dimensional and three dimensionality I'm
not going to call that God but this
split between my cognition and the sheer
physicality you know of material things
I'm gonna call that God all
approximations that we have beyond the
approximation the physical world is to
something beyond the approximation our
cognition is
thing but you're right it's perhaps
arbitrary to point a finger and say
there is God but all I can do is
represent ya we have to finish you
unfortunately because I don't want my
speakers to be overwhelmed by more than
20 minutes questions and grilling thanks
you all so much for coming and I hope
[Applause]